well la was odd because we left
Minnesota and we got in the car uh my
parents three children and my
grandmother and all squeezed in towing a
trailer Across America heading west and
I
at that point I thought California was
going to be Cowboys and Indians that's
what I'd seen on movies it was clear it
was an open space it was free from snow
and mosquitoes and all the things that
made life in Minnesota difficult and we
got there and of course it wasn't
anything like that because we moved into
a house in Panorama City which is in the
heart of the San Fernando Valley there
is no Panorama
but there it was and it had just been
built by Henry Kaiser Kaiser Aluminum or
aluminum in America and for those of you
who've seen Chinatown with Jack
Nicholson
You Know Jack Nilsson drives out into
the valley it's all Oak I mean uh orange
girls it's just beautiful and that's
what it was up until the year we moved
there and the year before they chopped
it all down and built identical houses
everywhere and and that was a bit of a
shock that that was not the California I
saw in the movies but the movies were
made around us there were different
places there's a place called Stony
Point that was some I know from our
house 20 minutes drive and a lot of the
old TV westerns were shot there so you
can actually go and climb around and
fall and do all the things you do in in
westerns on the actual location which is
really exciting did you have a sense
then that that's the world in which you
wanted to work live exist
no I don't have any I seldom really have
plans I fall into things I think
now movies were there they were really
much very obviously very much part of my
life all of our Lives it was you know
the world outside of of either Minnesota
or definitely outside of Hollywood and
what the big you know the band hers the
robes all the biblical ones were
fantastic because we're in this other
world so I always loved them I I didn't
really think seriously about movies
until I was in well I must have been
about 14 or 15 at the time and
the local cinemas you know five ten
minutes away and on a Saturday Saturday
matinees all the parents would dump
their children there get around away so
they could go shopping uh and uh
and so there we were and Kubrick's
Palace of Glory came up that was like
the first time I was aware films had
things to say other than just
entertaining right made you think it was
about Injustice it was the absurdity of
war and I was watching this while all
the the ten-year-olds were running up
and down the aisles jumping wanting more
ice cream and everything and I was
transfixed and I think that was the
moment that boom these things are
powerful they say things and I ought to
start taking them more seriously than
just entertainment at what point did Mad
Magazine enter your life
mad met with Bad Comics before Mad
Magazine Mad comics was started in the
in the 50s Harvey kurtzman was the
editor the best cartoonist of America
were writing there and
uh Wally Wood in particular was a great
cartoonist his women were so sexy it was
it was comic book porn for me basically
let's just get it's clear how old were
you Terry I was I was then 13. you know
oh yeah and he saw this he wasn't 23 or
four yeah no because you know at that
point
since point is so much a part of our
world now and you kind of way then the
best we could do was the Encyclopedia
Britannica the Greek sculpture section
Venus de Mila was the best I could come
up with when it came to babes yeah
but Mad comics was so funny because it
was satirical it was ironic it did
pastiches of comics and it turned you
sort of rather Bland Sunday uh morning
uh comic strips into real political
socio-political statements and they were
brilliantly funny uh they parodied
movies uh it was in a sense it really
wasn't since the Bible for my generation
of cartoonists we all grew up with it
because there was nothing like it and
and that was seeing mad seeing what was
being made with I mean at once they had
such an enormous readership 21 million I
think was it yeah huge bigger than the
Bible it may be interesting just for a
few days at least
um
was that the point was that sort of an
epiphany this I belong in this world
or at least I want to get into this yeah
I mean it was well I I never believed I
could get into any of those worlds to be
honest this is like well because I was a
local local lab I didn't know I didn't
know how you made the leap into the
um Olympia of whatever it was whether
it's movies or Comics but what I did do
is copy I learned to draw cartoons
trying to draw like Jack Davis or Wally
Wood any of them uh Willie Elder was
one of my favorites because he Harvey
kurtzman would write these stories he
would lay them out and then the
cartoonists would go to work and and
Willie is the guy that would add 10
million jokes to every cartoon uh frame
Harvey would write something funny the
character would be funny but Harvey
would fill it up with details it's which
I think is where I learned to fill the
background of my films up with all sorts
of things which maybe people won't even
see until the secondary third or fourth
viewing
that's really arrogance isn't it
[Laughter]
they'll watch it that many times
but wait till you see this for the 20
bit time it's a theory it was a theory
um and all of that was there so yes
one copied one admired it and
it took until College yeah where a
connection began to form because uh a
group of us took over the college
literary magazine a really fine
publication poetry fine writing and we
turned it into a cheap shoddy comic
magazine and the readership shut up
and and we just started playing with it
and we were very much by then I was very
much influenced by the next well not the
next bank but the fourth magazine after
mad that Harvey kurtzman did it was
called Help yes and and we would you
know we were much inspired by its
stealing things stealing formats the
ways of doing things and uh but that
that was the leap that basically when I
graduated with no plan I had been
sending those magazines to Harvey in New
York and he had written a nice letter
back saying you're doing some
interesting work terrific
and and I graduate from college working
at a summer camp no plans and you
graduating political science didn't you
yeah well yeah let's do what this is
like the book where I start telling a
story that I get distracted by something
else but it's more interesting that way
we can park that one for the moment
no and in college
I got to go to college because I was
smart in high school I was beyond
wonderful I was student body president
head cheerleader I was King the senior
problem I was valedictory there was
nothing I could not do
anyway or so I believed and
and so I got a scholarship to Occidental
College it's the only way I could go to
the school it was a very fine college
and it was costly and I got there
because I got a scholarship and actually
it wasn't just purely on my academic
credentials it was also a presbyterian
scholarship because my work in the the
local church group so God was very much
involved in my advancements uh or at
least just Representatives via John Knox
and others it's like and so and so I go
to college and it's smart because the
first time I was really around rich kids
and because the school was expensive so
either you had to be very smart or have
very rich parents to go there and that
really changed
so much because at that point we're
talking 1958 now
and that was when practical jokes were
still popular and if you're a rich kid
you can do really expensive practical
jokes
um with very little and that sense of
privilege that rich kids have I mean we
would do or they would do and I would
learn to do them jokes like
for example okay
um you take the room in the dorm and you
fill it up with newspaper you crunch up
the papers a lot you need a lot of
friends to do this and you fill it up
from floor to ceiling wall to wall door
to window and it you can't move it's
full of paper but then there's another
thing you do you take the bed of this
person whose room it is who is away for
the weekend uh and you hang it out the
window and you have a rope holding that
that that bed and you then run it
through the window straight through to
the door and you then tie it to the door
handle now you pull the door too but
there's one more trick you've got to
pull the pins out of the hinges so the
only thing holding the door in position
is the lock
that's it so the guy after a nice
weekend comes back pissed out of his
mind puts the keys in the door and Wham
and that's what we do we would do things
like that I I of course didn't
um but the rich kids did I mean at one
point they actually took an old Model T
Ford and we took it apart reassembled it
put it in the room and had the engine
running but the guy came back
in that kind of atmosphere I I was
inspired I guess
special effects special effects but what
I loved about that kind of practical
joke it was more work preparing and
doing the ultimate effect the setup
everything and I thought that's great
and I don't care how destructive the
joke was if the setup was much more work
than the end result that was and it
really made me think very differently
about things but with the Humor Magazine
we were doing that we also there was
another thing we did I I was again a
cheerleader there's a good thing about
being a cheerleader you jump around wave
your hands and you're with the girls
which are really pretty girls there and
you're making a fool of yourself in
front of a lot of people just like this
and um and it's and it was great fun and
this little group of us who had the
magazine we took over what was called
the Bengal board which was in charge of
school spirit now if Goebbels had gone
to oxidad he would have been in charge
of just that uh just that
um and and and so we were inspired by
the little man with a limp and and we
we started uh well we didn't start we
just did one year the Freshman would
arrive and that was a time in college
was when freshmen would be hazed they
would have to go through all sorts of
indoctrinations you know various things
to get into the select world of this
college well we started this series up
in a Greek Theater which was just above
the main part of the campus and we
started these you know these torch-lit
um assemblies
um nirenberg was a small time compared
to what we were doing here and it's like
and the Freshman would be paraded in it
was all done very ritualistic and then
we would that evening uh tell them the
traditions of the college and imbue them
with all the knowledge that they would
need to survive
this is all invented the night before
um and but what was extraordinary about
it the Freshman believed it all that
year but what was interesting that's in
in the same period of time the seniors
who had been there for four years had
accepted that as a truth
and I thought the big lie does work it
really does but we were doing it for fun
we weren't doing it to try to light up
with Humanity I'm delighted there were
no pigs involved anyway so
um
so you start sending your cartoons in to
help and eventually you get a gig there
yeah you you're working on help
and then John Cleese comes over to New
York as part of a reinvention of the
Footlights this Cambridge Footlights
you see him and invite him to come in
and do an animation with you it wasn't
now it's it's called fumetti fumetti
which is like it's basically doing a
cartoon with all the different cartoon
frames except it's live action it's
photographs people speak with balloons
that's what the fumetti is a puff of
smoke yeah oh sorry uh and and this is
what this thing help was doing Harvey
had invented this it was it was
fantastic in fact it was kind of how I
learned to make movies because you need
actors costume sets locations all that
so I was on the lookout it was my job of
assistant editor looking for cheap
actors we could pay as much as 15 a day
um and and there was Cambridge
Footlights and it was called I can't
remember what it was called they look
cheap you thought yeah well there was
Bill Arty there was John there was
Graham Chapman uh David hatch who went
on to be BBC one right a running show
um and kimbrook Taylor and of course
John as always stands out from the crowd
and I asked him if he would be in this
fumatti that my roommate at the time had
written and and that was the beginning
of this relationship what was also
interesting to decide the story was
about a man who falls in love and I
believe has sexual congress with his
daughter's Barbie doll
a Blonde Barbie doll now I don't want to
say anything about John's four wives but
[Laughter]
we'll leave it there
there is a little bit of niggle among
the pythons